[Music]
on this sunday night russian air strikes
on nato's doorstep
dozens are killed after missiles strike
a military training base once used by
canadian soldiers not far from the
polish border if russia attacks fires
upon
takes a shot at nato territory
the nato alliance would respond to that
growing fears over a global conflict and
advice for parents on how to talk about
the war give them the information that
they that they want to see
hard to hear what research reveals about
how covid19 infects our ears
plus honoring a century-old sacrifice
paying tribute to canada's so-called
black battalion
global national
reporting tonight
jeff semple
i'll take a look these new pictures
reveal what's left of a military base in
western ukraine after russia fired more
than 30 missiles killing dozens and
raising fears about the war spilling
beyond ukraine's borders
good evening and thank you for joining
us the war in ukraine is now at nato's
doorstep those russian air strikes hit
just a short drive from the border with
poland a nato country and not far from
the ukrainian city of levive that's
where we find our mike armstrong tonight
mike
well jeff the attack happened almost at
first light about 6 30 a.m here local
time
driving to the base this morning we
passed literally dozens and dozens of
ambulances smoke was visible from
several kilometers away we were able to
reach the base but were told not to take
images the soldiers at the site were
understandably on edge
there are videos and stills on social
media that show just how destructive
this attack was
there were so many injured they were
taken to hospitals all across the region
at one facility a medical worker told us
one of the locations hit was a kitchen
that some of the people killed and
injured were preparing food
according to local officials 30 missiles
were fired from planes that took off
from a base in russia about 1500
kilometers away air defenses would have
shot some down but eight made it through
now the base was the headquarters for
canada's training operation in this
country
up unifier ran programs for ukrainian
soldiers in other regions as well but
the yavariv base was its hub
prime minister trudeau visited in july
of 2016.
canada pulled its troops out of ukraine
this past february just prior to the
russian invasion in recent weeks the
base has been used for training and
staging a tweet last week from one of
the president's advisors and a lead
negotiator promoted the base describing
it as having overcrowded training areas
there were foreign fighters who went
through the facility as well one of them
told us yesterday he expected the base
to be a target less than 24 hours later
it was hit
a russian military spokesman made it
clear those foreign fighters were one of
the reasons the base was targeted he
claims a large number were killed and
foreign weapons destroyed now the base
is very close to the polish border just
20 kilometers that location is making
some nervous
a stray missile is something nato has
considered a special line of
communication has been set up between
washington and moscow to prevent an
escalation over an accident we can talk
to the russian ministry of defense that
system is working that line is working
and we will absolutely not hesitate to
use it if we need to
this ukrainian soldier says the missiles
could have landed on the other side of
the border and calls on europe to get
involved immediately
now i spoke to a couple of canadian
soldiers who were part of the training
mission and who in recent years spent
time at that base they know it they know
people who work there
this was a tough day jeff
and another anxious night mike armstrong
in la vie of ukraine thanks mike and
several other areas of ukraine were also
hit by renewed russian shelling at least
one person was killed in an airstrike
that destroyed this residential block in
the northern city of chernehief
firefighters rescued several people from
the burning building ukraine's emergency
service also shared this video showing
an unexploded bomb being removed from an
apartment building much of the city has
been heavily damaged by airstrikes
and american journalist and
award-winning filmmaker brent renaud was
killed in an attack just outside of the
ukrainian capital his colleague was also
hurt and is now being treated in
hospital he says they were shot by
russian forces
we cross one the first bridge in nirping
we're going to film other refugees
leaving
and we got into a car somebody offered
to take us to the other bridge
and we cross the checkpoint and they
started shooting at us
so the driver turned around and they
kept shooting
the head of the kiev region police
posted these photos on facebook
confirming the 50 year old journalist
had died renault was wearing a new york
times press badge but he was not on
assignment for the paper at the time
and bowing to pressure the united states
now says it will supply ukrainian
fighters with more weapons and security
assistance but despite calls to take
more drastic measures such as a no-fly
zone the biden administration insists it
will not support any actions that risk
direct conflict with russia jennifer
johnson has those details from
washington
hours after waves of russian missiles
pounded a military training base on
ukraine's border with poland
the u.s struck back pledging more
weapons to help ukrainian fighters
defend their country
we are determined and the ukrainians are
determined to ensure that anti-tank
anti-armor anti-air capabilities
ammunition
and other forms of assistance actually
do make it to the front to blunt the
russian advance
ukraine is pleading with the u.s and its
allies almost hourly for more military
power what we are asking is very simple
thing we say army ukraine and we will do
the rest
give us all the weapons necessary and we
will fight for our own land and for our
people the russian attack followed
threats by the kremlin to target foreign
weapons shipments in poland headed to
ukraine the white house still says it
will not put u.s soldiers on the ground
or military jets in the sky above
fearing a broader war with nuclear-armed
russia ukrainian officials already fear
vladimir putin could resort to using
nuclear weapons putin so can he can use
nuclear weapon because if he bombed and
killed russian troops on peaceful cities
children a woman they bombed children
hospital so they can do everything a new
cbs news poll shows 73 percent of
americans support a military response
only if russia attacks a nato country
but ukrainian americans fear there will
be nothing left of ukraine if the u.s
and its allies don't do more the entire
world is with ukraine and we're fighting
for democracy there are now over 9 000
u.s soldiers in poland there only to
defend the nato country as russian
military strikes get closer and closer
jennifer johnson global news washington
prime minister justin trudeau has just
returned home after spending a week in
europe discussing next steps to support
ukraine and push back against russia but
what did that trip actually accomplish
our abigail beeman on the canadian
contribution
talking ukraine with about a dozen world
leaders justin trudeau stopped in four
countries in four days
it's been about solidarity and alignment
amongst
leaders across europe and indeed around
the world
but more than that it's about concrete
supports that includes 117 million
dollars to help more ukrainians reach
canada new sanctions and an extension of
canada's nato mission in latvia but
according to government sources speaking
before the trip the goal was also to
push ideas forward and launch new ones
with maximum impact to stop russia
though there was no public evidence of
that are there new ideas being discussed
behind the scenes that you just can't
share
yes there are
we need we need to work on them with our
partners because
that's how we can be most effective
a senior government source pointed to
time with the new german chancellor as
especially key trudeau and olaf schultz
spent an unscheduled three hours
together wednesday night the germans
really wanted to talk to us canada's
former ambassador to germany peter beam
says a lot happens behind closed doors
and being face to face makes a big
difference
you cannot do everything on a platform
that is virtual you can't go into the
corner with your fellow leader whether
it's boris johnson or mark ruta and say
look
can we start thinking about
long-term aid and humanitarian flows
what about
a global food crisis considering that
ukraine is the seventh largest
grain exporter simply having the
personal relationships with leaders
allows you to then react that much more
quickly when the next crisis point comes
as opposed to
yeah we zoomed once in 2020 and
so now we're going to do life and death
decisions together this former canadian
ambassador to ukraine says most nato
leaders are in a dilemma about what to
do next this trip didn't solve that
dilemma
because it's a very difficult one
while the opposition calls for more
action
canada needs to have some more concrete
examples
of what we can do we need to make sure
that we are prioritizing defense
spending new democrats want more aid and
easier immigration pathways
it's important he's there he's at those
tables that he's participating
should they and could they have done
more and can do more 100 percent
pushing back against russia while no one
can predict vladimir putin's next move
abigail beeman global news ottawa
with so much horror and devastation the
war can be a difficult topic to address
with children but experts say there are
ways to help our kids understand and to
cope sarah ryan explains
for the solomons the war in ukraine hits
close to home they did missionary work
there for five years their youngest
child lived there longer than here she
wakes up every morning and she goes our
friend's still alive and i never thought
i'd have to deal with that as a parent
although a bit older their sons have
concerns too
our 12 year old he has big questions he
wants to know why humanity
is kind of acting this way
what is the purpose of it
registered psychologist dr brent
mcdonald says war is a challenging thing
for anyone let alone children to
understand what i really encourage
parents to do is first of all check in
with your kids to see what they do know
and what their what their understanding
of what's happening is
because there's probably going to be a
lot of misconceptions
he says kids need to feel safe he
suggests using a map to show where
russia ukraine and canada are in
relation to one another but pretending
this war isn't happening is
counterproductive ignoring what's
happening around us is
i would argue in pretty much any
situation not effective particularly for
kids because that becomes a habit
children are still hearing about what's
going on be it online or in school
certainly this is being talked about in
our classrooms and it's being talked
about in a way
that is respectful certainly and isn't
keeping in mind that this this could
could be trauma inducing for some of our
students mcdonald encourages focusing on
positives like humanitarian efforts it
doesn't mean we have to be into the
the gory details of everything but we
can give them the information that they
that they want to see that they want to
hear
at their level
the solomons are just trying to do their
best
talking with them it's been very
difficult
we try to be realistic
but we also try to help them to
understand
what
is going on
sarah ryan global news
still ahead medical mystery
investigating a lingering symptom of
covid19
for the first time in months the
montreal canadiens played in front of a
full house last night after more covet
19 restrictions were lifted in quebec
attendance was nearly 21 000 at the bell
center as the habs fell to the seattle
kraken four to three fans also no longer
need to show proof of vaccination to
attend the games
two years into the pandemic and
scientists are still unraveling covet 19
mysteries and one of them is a hearing
issue tinnitus a constant ringing in the
ears has been reported by thousands of
covid19 patients and as jamie morocco
reports experts are closer to
understanding the link between the virus
and that aggravating auditory ailment
teresa huff rang in 2022 with what she
calls a mild case of covid but it's the
symptoms she thinks the virus left
behind that has her searching for a
solution
i noticed it probably the first week in
february but it may have even been
before that just at night the ringing
you know the ringing in my ears
that's just one example of tinnitus a
constant buzz whoosh or ringing in the
ears 37 percent of canadians have to
endure the annoying and uncomfortable
condition which is believed to be an
inflammatory response or a result of
stress and in march of 2021 a group of
researchers found tinnitus was reported
by 15 percent of covid patients
audiologist rex banks says pandemic
anxiety and isolation may be to blame
during the pandemic people who you know
are spending more time alone for example
they may be spending more time in
silence meaning that they may become
more aware of their tinnitus but there
is another possible explanation for the
last year researchers have studied the
inner ear cells of both humans and mice
and found covid19 does have the ability
to infect some of the cells which can
underlie problems with hearing or
balance the vaccine or covet is sort of
triggering
this inner inner hair cells to
exasperate their existing tinnitus you
know just like it's affecting smell or
taste
thousands of incidents of
vaccine-related tinnitus have been
reported around the world including six
cases in johnson and johnson's own
coveted shot trial still it's a rare
ramification and experts agree the
benefits of the vaccine far outweigh the
risk matt willis is boosted but it was
after his bout with covid in november he
says he too noticed the high-pitched
sound of tinnitus had become more
intense i have to find ways to try and
concentrate
and i'm not fixating on the
on the on the sound the whole time
drowning out the noise and learning to
live with a condition with no cure jamie
morrocker global news toronto
still ahead california's new plan to
keep edible food out of landfills
welcome back a stark reminder tonight of
canada's environmental impact this is
earth overshoot day the annual occasion
marked in canada the united arab
emirates and the united states it's the
day humanity has consumed more natural
resources than the planet can replenish
in a given year it means that just two
and a half months into 2022 we've
already overshot earth's ability to
replenish natural resources
composting and food waste recycling
programs are commonplace here in canada
diverting organic waste from landfills
helps to reduce methane emissions that
contribute to climate change but in the
united states those composting programs
are more limited california is now
hoping to change that by recovering
edible food before it gets tossed in the
trash rob malcolm explains
for the first time mandatory food
recycling has begun in california and
joy kleinberg a mother of five in the
city of davis is already ahead of the
game we've been doing this for at least
five plus years
california is now the first state in the
country to mandate food waste reduction
for businesses and residents alike sb
1383 is the biggest change to our trash
since we started recycling in the 1980s
the move was made in an effort to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions from landfills
what happens when waste goes to a
landfill organic waste it actually
breaks down into methane which is a
potent greenhouse gas
two-thirds of all waste in california is
organic and the state sees some 5.5
million tons of food waste end up in
landfills each year this new initiative
aims to dramatically reduce that so when
we reach our 75 goal of diverting
organic waste from landfills it is the
equivalent of taking more than a million
cars off the road for over a year since
landfills remain one of the largest
sources of methane gas production one of
the main goals of the new law is to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by 40
percent by the year 2030 and composting
isn't the only factor the state sees as
success a unique component of the law is
a requirement by businesses to recover
20 percent of the edible food waste that
might otherwise go into a landfill or a
compost bin from restaurants from
retailers such as grocery stores anytime
that they have food that they may have
thrown out before we want to first do a
do a look at it and see if we can
recover some of that food for edible
consumption but after a little more than
a month adjusting to the new laws some
food vendors are still trying to find
their footing we have
many issues the covet shutting down that
that seems to be probably one of the
least
concerning things that i have on my
plate but if they can provide it and
they can teach us how to do it great the
california department of resources and
recycling director says they know it
will take some time for the program to
become part of everyday life but they
are working on making it as seamless as
possible across the state we are giving
grants to local governments from
everything from the startup of their
collection partner to these educational
campaigns
joy has already seen the benefits of
composting and is proud that her state
has now made it law to do what she's
been doing for years i can definitely
say this is the one thing that makes me
very happy to be from california
rob malcolm global news sacramento
up next remembering the legacy and
sacrifices of canada's black battalion
the russian invasion of ukraine offers a
grim reminder of how wars can devastate
families communities and entire
countries but in canada there's a new
effort underway to recognize sacrifices
from more than a century ago
contributions that have been largely
overlooked until now ross lord has that
story
despite a topic steeped in racial
prejudice jerome downey points with
pride this is the late private george
alexander down he's from halifax his
great grandfather a veteran of both
world wars and a member of a remarkable
first world war unit the number two
construction battalion men who were
prevented from fighting in the war
because they were black they persevered
forming what became known as the black
battalion building rail lines trenches
and bridges for the soldiers they were
prohibited from fighting alongside
and creating a path of opportunity for
their descendants like army reservist
downey to be a graduate of university to
be a tradesman to be a business owner to
have the opportunities that i have
because of the sacrifices of members of
number two construction battalion means
a lot a connection reinforced by his
recent visit to the azura region of
france where the number two battalion's
efforts are memorialized at a
commonwealth gravesite soldiers who were
overlooked in canada for more than a
century but this summer the federal
government will issue an apology for the
racism that kept battalion members from
being full partners in the war effort
with growing awareness there are new
discoveries that we've just received in
our collection this violin donated to
nova scotia's black cultural center was
hand crafted by a soldier who'd been
part of the battalion's musical band
there's so much history that's hidden
and i think this is a great opportunity
to bring that to the forefront to ensure
that the legacy of the number two
continues on a legacy of determination
and sacrifice qualities everyone can
admire this isn't a black canadian story
this is a canadian story this is our
history that everyone can gravitate to
and hold too proud ross lord global news
dartmouth nova scotia and that is global
national for this sunday night i'm jeff
semple tonight we leave you with some
inspiring moments and passion from
canadian athletes at the paralympic
games in beijing which just wrapped up
today team canada put on its second best
showing ever at a paralympic winter
games winning 25 medals eight gold six
silver and 11 bronze an impressive haul
congratulations to team canada and thank
you for watching have a great night